Avengers ends game tilt on our
heartstrings plenty but a deleted scene
would have straight-up yanked on them
the scene in question recently made
available and Disney Plus depicts series
star visiting in a theory or after life
immediately after his universe saving
snap there he encounters an adult
version of his daughter Morgan wall ends
game directors Joe and Anthony Russo had
previously discussed the scene we had
yet to get a look at it before now and
it's every bit as poignant as you'd
expect in the scene Starks suddenly
finds himself alone in the peaceful
realm seemingly confused as to where
everybody went just as he begins to
realize what must be happening Morgan
makes her appearance at first stark
isn't sure who he's looking at but when
Morgan offers a clue that the two are
pretty close he figures it out pretty
quickly Starks face registers a thousand
of motions as he looks at the daughter
he'll never get to know and he admits to
wondering if he made the wrong decision
and sacrificing himself and of course a
scene ends exactly as you'd expect
there's amazing chemistry in the scene
between Robert Downey jr. and Catherine
Langford who unfortunately was robbed of
an appearance in the biggest movie of
all time when this scene hit the cutting
room floor it wouldn't surprise us
though
if Morgan stark were to make an
appearance in a future MCU film or
several in their commentary on the scene
at the Russo brothers explained that it
was conceived as a sort of bookend to a
scene in Avengers infinity war
specifically the scene in which Santos
having just accomplished his mission to
snap half of all life in the universe
out of existence was basically
transported inside the soul stone there
he encountered a young version of its
adopted daughter Gamora who was one of
the many people who died at Thanos his
hands so that he could accomplish his
mission Joe Russo explained we sent him
to what we would call the weigh station
to mirror what had happened to Thanos
Anthony Russo added that the idea is
that this moment the act of using the
Infinity stones a sort of forces you to
confront or reconcile something that's
unresolved in yourself in your soul Joe
then explained that the reason an adult
Morgan was cast was so stark could come
to terms of what he had done and truly
understand the fact that he was giving
up so much time spent with his daughter
throughout her life however at the end
of the day the scene was cut for reasons
that are pretty understandable when
you're talking about a flag that already
ran in excess of three hours pacing as
Joe Russo possess when we
what this in the film we felt like it
ground the movie to a halt and starved
us something similar in the next
sequence when he gives his own eulogy
via hologram at his funeral
the director continued to say that he
and his brother were mindful of adding
too many endings which is a problem that
popped up in The Lord of the Rings The
Return of the King audiences might have
felt like the film would ended on the
perfect sentimental note only fret to
continue on to another and another
according to Joe what can happen at the
end of the film this big is you can have
ending after anything after ending and
there's just a few like them the movies
never going to end in other words the
powers of the individual moments of
watts are down and the endings when you
have we have too many sequences in a row
you can dilute the value of each one of
them taking all of these things into
account the pair reluctantly decided
that a scene had to go still that
doesn't mean we can't admire its power
anyone in their right mind would have
met that there wouldn't have been a dry
eye in the house and its conclusion that
they left it in unfortunately only time
will tell whether Morgan stark will make
any further appearances in the MCU in
the meantime though you can revisit the
triumphs and tragedies of Avengers
endgame to your heart's content with a
Disney Plus subscription the movie is
available to watch on the new streaming
service right now check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos buy your favorite movies
are coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and to the bail so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]